Oh big guy no nobody's leaving don't be
stupid we love being united we love the
radiation the trichinosis we're in it
for life which i assume is around twenty
years average I just need a quick aside
with my grandkids about 40 yards from
anyone else
hey the green rock is gone I know why
don't we all split up and look for it in
groups of three kid Oh we'll be right
back new Rick and Morty is back this is
going to be so awesome everybody so I'll
be doing weekly videos and a weekly
merch giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video most of you probably
picked up on the Mad Max fury road
references but there were a bunch of
references from the entire Mad Max
series going all the way back to road
warrior Joel McHale and Tony Hale were
guest stars Joel McHale actually played
hemorrhage the guy that summer ended up
getting married to Tony Hale played the
announcer inside the blood tub
obvious reference to Thunderdome but he
was also the guy at the end of the
episode who was criticizing summer for
not putting her post-apocalyptic
recycling in the correct bin one more
thing we noticed that you've been
putting scrap metal in the blue bin I
got it
she's a piece of work they both are
right the clip that I included at the
beginning of this is Rick's fourth wall
break as he turns to the camera and says
whoo we'll be right back the title of
the episode Rick man seing the stone is
just a reference to Romancing the Stone
Michael Douglas Kathleen Turner movie
where they go after a giant I think it's
an emerald it might be a green rock but
I also thought the green rock you know
which looked kind of like kryptonite
might be a reference to battle the
Planet of the Apes where they're
worshipping an atomic bomb like the
people in this post-apocalyptic earth
are worshipping this mysterious green
rock that Rick is like hey this is a
giant energy source you could use this
to power all your houses but if you
notice the opening title sequence
there's actually a couple Easter eggs in
that morty store where he's got negan's
bat he winds up settling on Morty with
the master sword from a Legend of Zelda
Justin roiland is a bit of a toy nut
like he has this giant toy collection so
I just love the idea that the morning
store is basically a giant action figure
store that Rick goes shopping at every
once in a while at the beginning when
they're in that Mad Max fury road
sequence being chased down by the
scavengers the immortan joe character is
the first person she kills summers gun
is right out of the road warrior so she
takes him down and because of that they
invite her to join the scavengers she
eventually becomes the Tina Turner
character from beyond the Thunderdome
which is actually a pretty amazing
costume this is probably one of the best
alternate versions of summer that I've
ever seen before
Joel McHale is character hemorrhage is a
parody of that beyond the Thunderdome
character master and blaster he's the
blaster that's the big guy that wears
the giant helmet they even have their
own little guy too but that's more of a
Mad Max fury road little guy character
they're a bunch of little characters in
the Matt back series it kind of felt
like Morty's possessed armed with
something from that movie idle hands
where he literally has like the devil
hands it's attached to him that tries to
kill people and he can't control it
the Morty and summer robots felt like a
West world reference where they sort of
override their programming gained
consciousness in Morty's like I want to
feel I want to love and run in the
stream
Rick changes their programming on the
fly using vocal commands just like 4
does and takes them out in the garage
and smashes them once they bring the
real Morty and summer back haha jeez my
sisters are the speakers that's remote
override engaged no yes bypassing
override I am aha hello there weren't
any real references where Jerry got his
social security check eaten by the dog
at the end I was just rubbing salt in
his wound in Justin roiland soft voice
on the wind calling him a loser a lot of
people thought that was Rick's voice
taunting him but I feel that it was just
Justin roiland literally playing the win
like the earth itself was just calling
him a loser
overall it was a great episode it was
all about the family moving forward
without Jerry so obviously the kids were
stuck in their rut and they were trying
to deal with it in this post-apocalyptic
world summer winds up getting married to
hemorrhage then goes through almost the
exact same divorce scene that Beth and
Jerry had during episode 1 this scene
where she comes in with the garbage he
gets all pissed off with him because
he's been sitting around watching the
Blood dome finals all day you haven't
killed a single person today probably
one of the best scenes in the episode
I'm home I'm home you haven't moved
since I left to scavenge this morning
blood don't playoff so i can assume you
haven't murdered a single person today
oh I don't know I didn't mark my murders
in my murder log I didn't know that's
how we measure success oh there he is
there's the nihilistic brute I married
except now life only means nothing when
I'm talking to him
and everything means everything when
it's on TV you probably also noticed
that the inside of this living room here
looks exactly like the living room that
Rick and Beth are in in all the promos
that they've been releasing so maybe
they go back there during this season or
maybe they just used it for this
particular animation they went back to
Cronenberg world in episode 1 so you
never know but I almost forgot if you
don't remember big Johnson was actually
a brand of t-shirt it was actually
pretty ridiculous I think it was from
the late 90s but this was an actual
t-shirt that people wore around what
will happen is is I'm working on my Game
of Thrones episode 4 trailer video
that'll post later tonight but I'll do a
Rick and Morty promo video for next
week's episode after that so a whole
bunch of Rick and Morty and Game of
Thrones coming a little while my videos
for Rick and Morty will just post Monday
mornings until Game of Thrones is done
then I'll probably try to start posting
them a little bit earlier but it airs
really late at night like 11:30 p.m. so
usually by the time I would finish most
videos people are asleep so it doesn't
make sense to upload them right after
the episode anyway congratulations to
the latest merch giveaway winner
b:g studios you win a $20 gift card for
the Zen monkey studio store please
private message me so I can get your
contact details I'll announce a new
winner when I post my next Rick and
Morty video that'll probably be tomorrow
while you wait for every
you can click here for my Game of
Thrones episode video from last night
and you can click here for more Rick and
Morty season 3 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]